ซูเปอร์คอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิกที่ดีที่สุดของเรามีประสิทธิภาพเพิ่มขึ้นเรื่อยๆ
และเราก็เก่งขึ้นในการคำนวณ รวมถึงการจำลองระบบต่างๆ
แต่การจำลองธรรมชาติเป็นปัญหาที่ยากมากโดยทั่วไป
ฉันชื่อ Victoria Lipinska และวันนี้เราจะมาสำรวจหนึ่งในอัลกอริทึม
ที่อาจทำให้การจำลองธรรมชาติเป็นไปได้บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
มาเริ่มด้วยตัวอย่างกัน ลองมาดูที่คาเฟอีน
มันเป็นโมเลกุลที่เรียบง่าย
เพื่อแทนค่าการกำหนดค่าพลังงานของโมเลกุลคาเฟอีนเพียงตัวเดียว
เราต้องการบิตประมาณสิบยกกำลัง 48
นั่นคือเลขสิบตามด้วยศูนย์ 48 ตัว
และมันคือประมาณ 10% ของจำนวนอะตอมทั้งหมดในโลก
และมันยิ่งแย่ลงไปอีก
ถ้าคุณมี 125 ออร์บิทัลและต้องการเก็บทุกสถานะที่เป็นไปได้
คุณต้องการหน่วยความจำมากกว่านี้
ในคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิกของคุณมากกว่าจำนวนอะตอมทั้งหมดในจักรวาล
นั่นเป็นสิ่งที่เป็นไปไม่ได้สำหรับซูเปอร์คอมพิวเตอร์
แต่ยังมีความหวังสำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
เพราะมันถนัดในการจำลองธรรมชาติโดยธรรมชาติ
สำหรับโมเลกุลคาเฟอีน นั่นหมายถึงการแทนค่า
ระบบโดยใช้ 160 qubit
ฟังดูจัดการได้ง่ายกว่ามาก
มีการเสนออัลกอริทึมควอนตัมหลายตัวที่ช่วยให้
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมขนาดเล็กจำลองธรรมชาติแบบ heuristic ได้
ขอแนะนำ: variational quantum eigensolver หรือ VQE
VQE เป็นอัลกอริทึมที่รันบางส่วนบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
และบางส่วนบนคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก
มันช่วยให้เราหาค่าที่แก้ปัญหาการ optimization ที่กำหนดได้
VQE มีความสัมพันธ์ใกล้ชิดกับวิธีการอื่นๆ ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับ
การเปลี่ยนแปลงพารามิเตอร์ เช่น quantum approximate optimization algorithm
การระบุการประยุกต์ใช้ VQE ในอุตสาหกรรมหรืองานวิจัยของคุณ
เป็นทั้งศาสตร์และศิลป์ แต่มีแนวทางคร่าวๆ อยู่
โดยทั่วไป VQE เหมาะกับปัญหาที่สามารถแปลง
เป็นปัญหา optimization ที่มีตัวแปรต่อเนื่องได้
ซึ่งเป็นกรณีของเคมีควอนตัมเป็นส่วนใหญ่
บ่อยครั้งในเคมี เราสนใจ ground state
Ground state คือสถานะที่มีพลังงานต่ำที่สุดของระบบ
เพื่อหาพลังงาน ground state VQE จะสำรวจ
พลังงานในการกำหนดค่าต่างๆ ของระบบ
และค้นหาการกำหนดค่าที่มีพลังงานต่ำที่สุด
ในระดับสูง VQE รับคำอธิบายของระบบควอนตัมเข้ามา
และค้นหาพลังงานที่ต่ำที่สุด
โดยทำการเปลี่ยนแปลงการกำหนดค่าของระบบ
เพื่อเริ่มต้น เราต้องป้อนคำอธิบายที่เหมาะสมของระบบ
ที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเข้าใจ และชุดพารามิเตอร์ที่อธิบายระบบนั้น
ซึ่งจะถูก optimize
ส่วนควอนตัมของ
อัลกอริทึมจะเตรียมระบบให้อยู่ในสถานะ
ที่อธิบายโดยชุดพารามิเตอร์ที่กำหนด และคำนวณพลังงาน
ในขณะที่ส่วนคลาสสิกมีหน้าที่
optimize พารามิเตอร์เหล่านั้นในแต่ละขั้นตอน
กระบวนการควอนตัม-คลาสสิกนี้ถูกทำซ้ำ
จนกว่าเราจะถึงพลังงานที่ต่ำที่สุด
ทีนี้มาซูมเข้าไปดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นภายใน
การกำหนดค่าพลังงานมักอธิบายด้วย Hamiltonian
และโดยทั่วไปมันเป็นเมทริกซ์ขนาดใหญ่มาก
ในพีชคณิต เพื่อหา eigenvalue ที่ต่ำที่สุดของเมทริกซ์
ซึ่งสอดคล้องกับพลังงานต่ำที่สุดของระบบ
เราก็แค่ทำ singular value decomposition
แต่เมทริกซ์ที่เราจะดูนั้นมีขนาดใหญ่แบบ exponential
และมันยากแบบ exponential ที่จะทำวิธีนี้แบบพีชคณิต
Hamiltonian นี้ต้องถูกแทนค่าในรูปแบบ
ที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมสามารถเข้าใจได้
ก็คือแปลจากภาษาเคมีเป็นภาษาการคำนวณควอนตัม
ไม่ต้องเป็นห่วงเรื่องรายละเอียดนะ
ท้ายที่สุดแล้วมีวิธีที่ตั้งโปรแกรมได้ในการแปล Hamiltonian ที่มักพบ
ในเคมีให้เป็น Hamiltonian ที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเข้าใจได้
จากนั้นเราป้อน
Hamiltonian นี้พร้อมกับ circuit ที่เราเรียกว่า variational form
การเลือก variational form เป็นทั้งศาสตร์และศิลป์
อีกครั้ง
มันแทนการเดาที่ดีที่สุดของเราว่า quantum state ของระบบอาจเป็นอะไร
variational circuit นี้ถูกกำหนดพารามิเตอร์ด้วยชุดพารามิเตอร์ theta
และเรายังป้อนค่าเริ่มต้นของพารามิเตอร์เหล่านี้ด้วย
จากนี้ ส่วนควอนตัมของ VQE:
เตรียม reference state เช่น zero state
ใช้ parameterized quantum circuit หรือ variational form เพื่อเตรียม quantum
state สำหรับการเดาพารามิเตอร์เริ่มต้นบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม และประมาณค่า
พลังงานที่สอดคล้องกับสถานะที่ประเมินผ่าน Hamiltonian
การประมาณพลังงานนี้จะถูกส่งต่อ
ไปยัง classical optimizer ซึ่งจะหาชุดพารามิเตอร์ใหม่
พารามิเตอร์เหล่านั้นจะวนกลับไปยัง quantum solver อีกครั้ง
และกระบวนการทั้งหมดก็ทำซ้ำ
คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมหาการประมาณพลังงานใหม่
classical optimizer หาชุดพารามิเตอร์ใหม่ และวนต่อไปเรื่อยๆ
เราทำซ้ำกระบวนการนี้จนกว่าผลลัพธ์จะ converge
นั่นคือจนกว่าความแตกต่างของผลลัพธ์ระหว่างขั้นตอนจะเล็กพอ
สำหรับความต้องการของเรา
ในท้ายที่สุด อัลกอริทึมจะคืนค่าพลังงานที่ minimize แล้วนั้น
โอเค นี่มันดีมาก
แต่คุณอาจสงสัยว่าเรารู้ได้ยังไงว่ามันใช้งานได้จริง
และเราจะไม่ได้พลังงานที่ต่ำกว่าที่เราตามหาโดยไม่ตั้งใจ?
นั่นเป็นคำถามที่ดีมาก
ปรากฏว่าเราไม่มีทางประมาณพลังงานที่ต่ำกว่านั้นได้เลย
นี่เป็นเพราะสิ่งที่เรียกว่า variational principle
variational principle ระบุว่า lower bound ที่ยิ่งใหญ่ที่สุด
ของพลังงานระบบนั้นมักจะเป็น
พลังงานต่ำที่สุดที่สอดคล้องกับ ground state นั้น
ซึ่งหมายความว่าพลังงานที่ประเมินในสถานะอื่นๆ ของระบบนั้น
จะมากกว่าพลังงานต่ำที่สุดเสมอ
ดังนั้น ด้วย VQE เราจะไม่มีทางได้ค่าที่
ต่ำกว่าพลังงาน ground state
แต่เราก็อาจ converge ไปยังค่าที่
มากกว่าค่าต่ำสุดที่เราตามหาได้
สิ่งนี้มักเรียกว่า metastable solution
และมันเป็นความท้าทายที่นักวิจัยพยายามแก้อยู่ทุกวัน
VQE มีประโยชน์เพราะใช้ circuit ที่ตื้นกว่า
เมื่อเทียบกับโปรโตคอลอื่นๆ ที่ช่วยให้เราประมาณพลังงาน ground state
ทำให้มันเหมาะกับฮาร์ดแวร์ควอนตัมในระยะใกล้
ในวิดีโอนี้ เราได้เห็นภาพรวมว่า VQE ทำอะไรได้และถูกสร้างขึ้นมายังไง
แต่ฉันขอแนะนำให้คุณลองสำรวจ Qiskit ในบริบทนี้ด้วย
แม้ว่าเรายังอยู่ในช่วงเริ่มต้นของการเดินทางควอนตัม
คุณอาจพบว่ามันมีประโยชน์สำหรับปัญหาที่คุณพยายามแก้อยู่แล้ว
ฉันชื่อ Victoria Lipinska และนี่คือภาพรวม
ของอัลกอริทึม variational quantum eigensolver